let's just remind you of how the boycott
of BBC football programs unfolded well
Ian Wright who is one of the show's main
pundits tweeted uh first uh to say
everybody knows what match of the day
means to me but I've told the BBC I
won't be doing it tomorrow solidarity
then one of the other main co-presenters
on Match of the day Alan Shearer then
tweeted to say he also won't be on the
program simply writing I have informed
the BBC I won't be appearing on Match of
the day tomorrow night
then this morning BBC Sports Kelly
Summers also joined the boycott tweeting
just to confirm I won't be on BBC
television today
and in the last half an hour the final
score presenter Jason Muhammad tweeted
saying as you know final score is a TV
show very close to my heart however I
have this morning informed the BBC I
will not be presenting the show this
afternoon on BBC One as final score
reporters we have decided to stand down
from our duties today in solidarity with
Gary lineker as a result no final score
will be broadcast today we all love the
BBC and are proud to work for such a
great broadcaster
and again are these coming through thick
and fast in the last few moments the
final score commentator Chris Wise has
also tweeted to say just to confirm that
I won't be working for BBC final score
today the program is not going ahead all
of us need to stand together